this administration has been an
administration of projection I think is
the word I want to use or an
administration of the pot calling the
kettle black just about everything that
Donald Trump criticized President Obama
for he's guilty of himself Obama
played golf and that was bad according
to now President Trump but Trump plays
way more golf Obama was to blame every
time the stock market experienced a
decline even though overall during the
Obama administration stocks experienced
significant increases yet Donald Trump
takes credit only for the stock market
gains and not the recent precipitous
declines that we've had it's a very long
list Trump said in terms of his campaign
promises and projection and the pot
calling the kettle black Trump said he
would drain the swamp right but he's
actually filled the swamp with everybody
from Goldman Sachs executives and Wall
Street people and lobbyists it's a very
very long list that I've spoken to you
about many many times now but one of the
biggest areas where Trump would
endlessly slam Hillary Clinton was the
handling of sensitive secret and
classified information remember the
entire campaign and primarily when Trump
became the Republican nominee was all
about Hillary's careless humor Abaddon's
emails and Hillary's emails and
classified this and classified that but
Trump has been a total disaster on that
issue
Trump spilled secret information that
came from an ally to a Russian spy
recruiter in the Oval Office as we told
you before and the handling of security
clearances has been an absolute and
total disaster and we've now learned
we're learning more about this almost
every day as a result of the Rob Porter
scandal which we talked about last week
and I'll follow up about later today and
as a result of other scandals as well
we've learned that there are dozens of
White House employees including Jared
Kushner the golden boy Jared Kushner who
do not have to this day
almost 13 months into the Trump
administration they don't have permanent
security clearances and they are
regularly handling sensitive and
classified information and what's been
happening is that instead of actually
getting a proper permanent security
clearance Kushner and dozens of others
in the Trump administration have been
granted temporary clearances
now if the explanation was something
really simple like listen there's just a
backlog and these are people who of
course will all eventually get their
permanent security clearances that would
be suspect but it would at least be an
explanation that is not of major concern
but we now know that Rob Porter was
never going to get a permanent security
security clearance because of what was
in his background and we know that chief
of staff John Kelly knew that Porter was
never going to get that permanent
security clearance and yet allowed him
to continue working for about a year or
at least allowed him to continue working
for what ultimately became a period of
about a year and the White House is
simply not going to do the right thing
when it comes to this Jared Kushner is
another example a very notable example
he has had to change his security
clearance application multiple times
because he forgot to list hundreds of
contacts with foreign agents including
Russians this is absurd according to
legal experts it's no common occurrence
now individually you can say we'll
listen just the Kushner thing or just
the Rob Porter thing individually none
of these is a major risk in and of
itself but the big picture is that you
have an administration that ran on we
are against those who are inconsiderate
or sloppy when it comes to clearances
and classified information yet Trump has
dozens of people working for him who
lack permanent security clearances and
have access to secure sensitive and
secret information every single day it's
incredibly careless
it's incredibly sloppy and we're
Republicans on this right I thought
Republicans were super worried about the
handling of classified information they
claimed to be when they used that as a
reason why Hillary Clinton should not be
President of the United States and yet
they are mostly silent now and Trump and
Republicans ran a campaign against
Hillary Clinton on this issue and now
all of a sudden they don't care and as
I'll talk to you about a little bit
later disturbingly while Donald Trump is
mostly not even getting the presidential
daily briefings with the latest updates
on security information Jared Kushner is
and he still has no permanent security
clearance this is an administration that
has handed secrets directly to Russians
Kushner had the idea of making a back
channel to Russia that would be off the
books and unknown to the intelligence
community they've got dozens of people
working without permanent security
clearances but Hillary Clinton was not a
good candidate her Trump because she
sloppily handled classified and secret
information projection and the pot
calling the kettle black is the sort of
this is the epitome of that that we're
seeing from the Trump administration and
later on I do want to get to this just
absolutely despicable story that not
only is Trump not reading the
presidential daily briefings which we
kind of knew he didn't like reading he
now is also declining the brief the
briefing with even more frequency it's
an absolute disaster I'm on Twitter at
the Pakman the show is on twitter at
david pakman show we'll take a break and
just so many major stories today to talk
about today's program is sponsored in
part by brilliant if you watch our
channel or listen to the podcast yeah
you're into politics and you follow the
Daily News and you want to be informed
about the world around you but maybe you
also want to dig a little deeper and on
the program we talk about climate change
and taxes and Technology political
philosophy to really understand these
issues at a deeper fundamental level you
have to familiarize yourself with with
what's actually sort of underpinning all
of it and that's math and philosophy
and the hard sciences and social
sciences and that's where brilliant
comes in it's a truly unique and
innovative online learning service which
lets you master important real-world
math and science concepts this includes
probability and statistics logic and
problem-solving renewable energy climate
science criminology you name it and you
can get started right the second by
signing up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman the first 200 people
who do that at brilliant org slash David
Pakman will also qualify for 20% off an
annual premium membership that is
brilliant org slash David Pakman check
it out today